-Performing
"Don't Forget My Love,"
give it up for Diplo and Miguel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Remember the feeling of
my fingertips on your skin ♪
♪ And the way
that our kisses taste ♪
♪ Sweeter after drinking ♪
♪ And the way that I rage
into your love ♪
♪ While you breathe me in ♪
♪ Just so you can feel me with
you even when I'm not around ♪
♪ So you don't forget my love ♪
♪♪
♪ Love, love, love, love,
love, love, love, love ♪
Jimmy Fallon!
-♪ Don't forget my love ♪
♪♪
♪ Don't forget my love ♪
-Say, say.
♪ Love, love,
love, love, love ♪
♪ Don't forget my love ♪
♪ Love, love, love, love ♪
♪ Love, love,
love, love, love ♪
-♪ Don't forget my love ♪
-♪ Tantrums set fire,
two dice we roll ♪
♪ Excite your eyes,
inhale the love ♪
♪ Play in the dark ♪
♪ Rules break, why pretend? ♪
♪ We take what we can ♪
♪ You ride to the end,
to the sun ♪
♪ Push that weight on me
like a fiend ♪
♪ Let's rage in the moonlight,
calm ♪
♪ Like a shot rings out
in the darkness ♪
♪ So you don't forget my love ♪
♪♪
♪ Don't forget my love ♪
Let's go!
♪♪
Everybody out there in TV Land.
I want to hear you say.
♪ Say don't forget my love ♪
♪ Love, love, love, love ♪
♪♪
♪ Don't forget my love ♪
♪ Love, love, love, love ♪
♪ Love, love,
love, love, love ♪
♪ Don't forget my love ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]